milk
freshly curdled milk eggs straight from
the coop an area tracer share on him
show me what you sell so long
what is up everybody
it's Monday hope you're all doing well
hope you had a great week at Persia here
Jake is back I feel like I have not
streamed with you since like my first
stream ever here so it's exciting and of
course you guys Witcher 3 is coming out
on switch to Mario so we're gonna give
you guys a little sneak peek of the
action here and of course Jake our
resident what your professional is gonna
hold it down the gameplay and luckily
for you guys he's been playing quite a
bit and we don't have to start from the
very beginning but if you guys do want
to see you know roughly the first 15
minutes of the game on switch that is up
on gamespot comm Moraine amp so we are
20 hours in according to Jake and also a
big and like fight is coming up so yeah
I actually have to go back and repair of
course it depends what people want to
see like I don't know if people want to
see the story because right now I am
just kind of doing this story but I have
a bunch of side quests if people don't
want the story spoiled spoiled for them
we can switch that but I figure the game
is four years old so I can kind of at
this point but I am about to find out
what's killing the villagers down
warrant but I know it's going well I
know one of the things that's killing
the villagers and I need to go prepare
for it because hope everyone's doing
well see some familiar faces in the chat
and some fresh ones thanks for joining
us you guys crime says where is Eric
well actually Eric and Julio are on
vacation yeah Julio's well actually
together and I'm excited for them I
think in like Hawaii to like really like
awesome like dream destinations so
that's exciting I hope they have an
awesome time crime already making jokes
on switch you guys it actually like uh
handheld it looks pretty good the
greater pixel density makes it easier to
watch like it's pretty rough on see
docked
as you can see but it runs pretty well
so far I haven't really hit any like
major hitches with frame rate or any
like big frame dip so far it seems
pretty consistent which is nice that
being said I haven't seen the whole map
yet like I still need to go to novigrad
which is typically pretty can't be
pretty intensive but some of the swamps
down south when this game originally
came out were pretty intensive but you
know seems pretty solid so far yeah I
mean for a pretty big game you know
there has to be some give-and-take when
you're pouring into a switch I assume
but yeah
[Music]
shin-chan says a love game spot well we
love you thank you for joining my
charity stream this month asks Brandon
missing me talking about extra length
extra life end of the month
yeah I forget the exact dates but I
think it's a week from I think it starts
a week from Friday
yeah so next Friday which is pretty fun
ramping up to that mm-hmm I thought I
bought the thing I knew I guess I didn't
so I'm back and we have not hit okay
so anything so far in this version that
like stands out to you as far as you
know it being on switch now and stuff
like that um not really I mean it's all
the same same content more deals or all
the DLC is here like included with
mountain yeah
loading times are actually pretty
comparable to like ps4 and Xbox one not
pros I'm sure pros and X's are faster
but so far it seems not bad when you
thing is it in dialogue sometimes it
like cuts like a quick black screen I
think it needs to do that to load which
I noticed it more so doctor than
handheld interesting I can't find the
substance I need I can loot the liquor
cabinet in the Barons house hopefully
but yeah I mean I'm I'm just gonna do a
story I guess unless people want to see
something else yeah I mean you've
already talked up this fight coming up
sides definitely wanted to see the fight
before we hop on to anything else I just
have to find dwarven spirit cannot find
it what about you Chad are you guys
excited for Witcher 3 on the switch I
kind of like that all the expansions are
included that's convenient yeah it's
definitely nice and I know a lot of
people who played The Witcher 1 but
never really got around to the
expansions unfortunately with this you
can just skip right to those expansions
if you want which some of the like might
may not be a bad way to do a lot of
those expansions or two of the two main
expansions because they're shorter and
they're they're a good time Secor I said
why would anyone buy this on switch
I mean don't underestimate the power of
having games on the go that's something
that over time I feel like I've started
to really really appreciate especially
when I you know have to travel
frequently and you know that even
includes
ball games I think mobile games have
been stepping it up too so I actually
really like games on the go and if it's
a game that's like I've liked for a long
time and then it's like ported on to a
portable device I think I'm even better
here because I mean there are plenty of
games that I own for like every console
for no reason but I do anyways totally
that's like how I feel I have this game
on PC Xbox ps4 so my favorite games of
all time full disclosure and I'm like
sure this isn't the ideal way to play
this game but you know if I'm on the go
and I want to play some witch here I can
just play The Witcher I am well I've got
no luck no dorvan spirit I guess I could
just try to fight this guy without
farewell the decoction but can be kind
of tough I want to try another village
first Ryan asks have we done a live
stream for cod mobile yet we haven't but
I actually really like thank you it's
actually frequently yeah it's really
good and I've been seeing a lot of like
eSports heads doing like tips and tricks
videos for cod mobile and everything too
so I think everyone's really liking it
so far
alright there's for sure what I'm
looking for in this city
yeah Greg we're still making lots of
content you can always hop over to our
website or our YouTube page we're doing
a lot of things actually
including live gameplay so got a little
bit of it all yeah a lot coming up -
lots of games coming out of this month
next month the rest of the year
it's kind of been an action-packed
season yeah I thought the busiest would
be September but I was quickly proven
wrong when October started all right
this guy has that one of them how are
the mods on switch there are no do I
look like a witch I'm kind of missing
because on the PC version on like my
fourth or fifth run-through I had it so
my weapons don't degrade it's kind of a
pain having but back to repairing oh my
weapon I had armor
lpe asks a little off-topic but have you
checked out ukelele yes we have me and
Ben actually played that last week on
stream and it was a good time it was a
lot of fun and it even convinced Ben to
actually pick up the game afterwards
because that was his first time you know
getting a crack at it it was adorable as
awesome and actually had some pretty
League like Donkey Kong Country esque
elements so you're a fan of that game I
would highly recommend so any of you
guys I'm having no luck I'm also playing
on one of the harder difficulties so I
kind of go through resources pretty
quickly
unfortunately let me see might pick
something I had to hold back everything
in my being that's a title this team
this stream switcher a really really
tried so you know someone in chat was
like missed opportunity and I'm like I
know I know too tempting alright I'm
gonna try my luck without the without
the potion
see how this goes
you're right Brandon I do need to buy a
switch already I mean luckily I've been
getting away with just using the one in
the office when no one else is using it
but christmas is coming you know maybe
I'll treat myself or maybe Santa will be
nice to me busy all right we're back
here again I'm gonna fight the monsters
yes let's do it
yeah framerate is pretty close to the
ps4 version is it is actually like I
played I only played on ps4 when it
first launched and then I played on PC
so there I actually had a lot of
framerate issues on the ps4 version
especially in the crookback bog and I've
noticed at least from what I remember
this seems a little bit more solid
obviously you're not seeing like 60
frames a second like PC or anything like
that but I've been impressed so far
the one asks how much is it going to be
I think it is $59.99 for switch so you
know average price per game plus it also
comes with those expansions like we
mentioned earlier and so all increase
pack I don't see I think in the box it
comes with new stuff at least for the
original release it had like a map it
had like a little compendium they had
the soundtrack not sure if it comes with
all that but I know probably especially
knowing see Projekt RED it probably does
come up with some extra goodies if
you're into physical additions I
especially for switch I kind of just
like getting it all digital yeah then I
just have it all in one place but
occasionally I'll see a game that I
really want a physical copy up like this
since I ordered one of those
why Eagle says Geralt for smash I would
love that when they teased that Geralt
was coming to a fighting game before it
was it was ultimately for what so
calibers six six five six he though he
has full caliber vibes for sure I was
like I figured it was so calorie but I
was like but maybe maybe it's smash
first thing we're not scared to you
werewolf
okay I'll be a little bit I'm only a
little scared gotta put some cursed oil
on my sword I like this a little easier
come on
whoo dodge slice images Iron Chef says
are there any differences in performance
when in handheld versus document from
what I can tell not really they seems
pretty similar the only things when I
was playing a lot of man held this
weekend was that it looks better a just
because like I said before the pixel
density is greater so it's easier to
forgive a lot of the blemishes that you
can see here and then the other thing
was that I didn't notice as many like
dips to black and conversations so maybe
that's just easier to load since I think
it's a little bit of a lower frame rate
or a lower resolution so that's kind of
nice
so the problem with werewolves and he's
about to do it now mr. fast bad no I
burn them they like
yeah there we go all right yeah that was
easy
I was only one of the monsters oh there
is a big decision coming up so maybe
Jack help me decide what to do today I'm
on blood and broken bones I thought
about playing death march I did death
march on PC a couple years ago but I was
kind of worried how'd this wood performs
like I don't know if I want to subject
myself to that okay um so yeah just
blood and broken bones I'll swim
all right
why you got
are you here to grant me death or is my
freedom which
what should we do hmm ask who he is I'm
like first how many time to be played
it's like have you done a different
answer I know it happens both ways
pretty well they are felons curse the
year or so seven teachers the we've held
a twist
Lyle's they teach their strength from
the broth of human flesh
why did they kill you the girls watch
this night they do our quarter no I
studied that way
to die
I was attacked this is my
[Music]
all right chat what should we do should
I help the heart monster or should I
kill the heart monster I know what
happens either way I typically kill the
heart monster but I kind of want to do
it the other way and help them out this
time but I'll leave it up to chat we got
a little bit of a delay so it might take
a second I think but I mean you've seen
both which one do you like more without
spoiling what happens well I I normally
always do I normally always kill it
because I think I like that one more
because I haven't done helping it since
I like first place do it that's why I
kind of want to help it and see but I'll
leave it up to chat or if Chad doesn't
care I'll just help it
I usually spare it and help it probably
kill yeah it's always like so yeah yeah
okay all right all right oh yeah
whatever help oh you guys did so nice I
like crime subsidies I mean this is the
Witcher
individuals posture cold dark as the
bottomless well blah does the deputies
of such a beast no other gather wind
rooms
got some Raven feathers bring me a
witness Walter toss
why do we need a black horse oh come on
just spoil the ending of this question
yes it's like I said it's four years old
and I'm sure most people in chat of
article 8 is okay I'll gather what I
need to all right all right off to do
our daily good deed yeah help a tree
heart find the bones it's dry think I
see my silver sword is in danger right
now I got to repair that on the PC I had
a modded so I didn't have to repair
anymore so so tired going back and
repairing and spending all that coin
back to the struggle life whoa
angel says should I buy the same again I
already own two copies of the skins I
mean I would say that depends like do
you want to require it these did you
really like this game like i I I think
this is probably my favorite game of all
time so it's kind of a no-brainer when
they announced which I was gonna get
this but like if you just want to replay
it cuz you haven't played it in a while
like the best way to play this is is
like a console pc just because those
visuals are so good but like if you just
want another way to play this like me
like I'll probably slowly chip away at
this over time just because I can yeah
like when I go on trips and stuff like
that
so I it's totally worth it for me but I
mean it depends like depends on you know
how much money you want to spend how
much you think it's worth do you happen
to remember like how much the
expansion's costs Tufted for the other
versions of the game yeah so it was $10
for the first one $20 for the second one
but you could buy both for $25 like a
season pass
gallo game says witches in my hands yeah
pretty much a little bit that water can
almost catch you so close that I'm going
to meditate I need to think about that
one and it's one of the downsides of
playing on blood and broken bones there
when you meditate it doesn't heal you so
you have to heal yourself through other
means okay now I need to find a wild
horse
easy enough yeah
it's not my trusty Fresno leg wave can't
be bad easy
hey it's mom says can you guys do a
Mario Kart tour live stream we actually
did do a Mario Kart
to our live stream on its launch day
I'm actually not 100% sure of the past
broadcast of that is still up but we did
check it out and it was pretty close
interesting we tried you know all the
various control modes but I'm kind of
hoping for more out of that game coming
soon and like playing with friends and
stuff like that because I think at the
time it wasn't available but it's
definitely you know in the pipeline so a
lot of enemies around if I can take
oh yeah these are just all right that's
some humans
what's up big city thanks for joining us
happy Monday
he's just chillin under the bridge and
you're like nah get out of here get out
of there
like some real sword fighting yeah
there's the live yeah it was like give
us the good oh haha nice two birds one
stone hey they're going over here Horace
there we go I cheat a little yes bail
that's okay
Gerald's got things to do he's got Syria
to save the [ __ ] sorry if I mispronounced
that says greetings from Bulgaria hello
joining us
Blood Moon zero says I Loki you might
get this again
I mean if it's like what are your
favourite games it's like like Jake said
earlier a no brainer because I have
plenty of games where I own multiple
copies of it for every single console
and it's just how it goes
and like also if the switch is your only
means to play this game it's still
totally worth it like it is it is a
hundred hour long game easily more if
you want to spend more time in this
world this story is really good like
sure the graphics may not look as great
but I think the driving thing with this
game is its story and characters so sure
it may not look as pretty as you might
hope but at the end of the day you're
still gonna get that fantastic story
that that can change so much depending
on some of the smaller decisions you
make and it includes already off the
jump all the Downton like all the DLCs
yes probably even more than a hundred
hours if you really wanted to dig into
it alright I think we got everything
oh I have to bring it in what am i doing
I hope it didn't run away oh okay
what a very like well-trained wild horse
so you have here the framerate answered
it a little bit more but it's pretty
solid it doesn't hit 60 obviously I
think it I think it's about thirty but I
haven't noticed any framerate drops so
far occasionally some little things but
nothing that is really messed with my
experience at all
in fact it probably runs better on this
than I remember it ran on the ps4 back
in the day when it first launched I
think they patched it plenty of time now
for probably one's better
I can go back on it actually I'm gonna
kill you let's start the ritual this
poor Horace and worried for him I'm - I
don't remember what happened I offer
Raven feathers
I offer your remains nice monster cute
really wasted no time
[Music]
I free the children
all right I don't know if I would want
to ride him anymore it's pretty
terrifying
Italians humming this place of power
it's gotta be water Bob Jones welcome
back
the WHA says it looks fuzzy well we are
playing on the dock version but Jake
mentioned earlier that when it is in
handheld mode it definitely seems like a
better fit yeah totally an evil spirit
had possessed a tree on the hill it was
responsible for the killings how gee
dispel this evil didn't have to fight
anything or anyone
I simply freed the spirit you did wha
free the evil so it can prowl the world
as it well did what had to be done yeah
and if it returns ask the ladies of the
wood to help the crowns or the ladies of
the wood as you call them said to remind
you about payment take it you know what
they want
no he do give me the dagger be back soon
oh well do not expect that if you
thought that was a lot just wait just so
casually there is payment take it to the
ladies will you what the hell was that
it is our pact yeah you're a stranger
you don't know life here it's honest pay
for their protection so all those years
in the woods
put it out your mind master you soon
believe in and we must re on our young
uns and their young uns after him no
gods nor masters watch over melon
the land is nomads he wants to survive
must seek his own protectors
all right is this out on switch now
asked Mac bunker it comes out tomorrow
yeah so one more is it you guys and Bob
Jones with snow where this is this is
the early part of the game but we didn't
start from the beginning this is about
twenty hours in I'd say maybe a little
bit less
it's one of the coolest scenes in game I
think although it's very creepy
stuff of nightmares
oh yeah real life you're different then
you were in the tapestry when playing it
yeah
[Music]
yeah character design is incredible if
not scary stuff and I miss
maple thunders asking how am i liking it
one of my favorite games of all time I'm
impressed with how it runs so far
obviously it looks better on handheld
than it does dog guy's eyes creeping me
out punishments must be ash now silence
I know this is an ax away from the Baron
of crows perch
she belongs to no man she bears the mark
she's ours can it is another woman no
interests you speak quite head one
[Music]
our deal I did my part now you do yours
the world once given we never break the
girl mousy blonde that's what they call
it we cared for her as best we could
so just to catch you up the point of
this are the most of this game is Geralt
trying to find his daughter Syria
there's kind of daughter not not
actually his daughter daughter by choice
and she went through this bog that's why
girls here don't believe you they say
you always keep your word this is doing
everything exactly as it happened
[Music]
yeah that one which was just giving me
the heebie jeebies I have that weird
thing where like I can't really look at
like little circles altogether and so I
like freakin especially yeah
even the sound effects yep
elders
even though they're not blood-related
she does can either girl can take your
deep heck of a time to jump into the
Wichita let me tell you probably not
more than getting her feet stood ok so
they're also trying to catch ciri as
well mike says how's it performing
handheld I'm interested in playing this
in handheld only gonna be awesome
I prefer handheld definitely because it
it the like I said before the pixel
density is much higher so it's easier to
forgive these poor textures and
and resolutions jeez this is cool you
kind of get the players hurry now yeah I
can watch the worry within the story so
yeah I totally prefer playing this on
handheld if I wasn't reviewing it I
would probably be playing this on
handheld only how does it feel like I'm
the controller compared to on then
Oh controllers more comfortable for sure
especially over long periods of time but
like the thing I say especially with
like ports of games is that you don't
really need precise aiming with this
game for the most part there are
occasions where you might we don't
really need precise aiming so it's not
as demanding as something like doom or
Wolfenstein those kind of ports that's
that kind of tough to aim on those but
this having those smaller sticks aren't
really that bad yeah they don't really
come and do a problem
oh yeah I'll turn on subtitles after
this cutscene yeah I have played the
witch you're on PC which is there in
this
yeah the search buttons are small but
like it depends like if that doesn't
bother you then may not bother you it
hasn't bothered me so far definitely
feels a little more cramped than having
an actual controller but I prefer I'd
prefer playing this handheld than docked
but I guess the way prefer to play it
over that is on a PC with a controller
yeah no definitely when it's in hand
holla'd can't like it's a lot better but
you know such a shame you she fled she
escaped you but I'll find her we'll come
back here together and kill you
your return you shall our feets about
and one will die but it's shown to be
one of us each time you see her she will
be ash and if you find her
[Music]
[Music]
all right done with that don't want to
hang out with those witches anymore
duck asks hi are the game mechanics
quick to pick up or is there a learning
curve because I've never played this
game before there is a learning curve
but you can play on easier difficulties
and it's more forgiving like if you plan
an easier difficulty pretty much all
you'll really need to know it's like how
to swing your sword heavy and light and
how to dodge and stuff like that if you
play harder then you have to brew
potions you have to I'm not fighting all
these then you'll have to prove potions
you'll have to engage with some of the
more the deeper systems in the game
which is rewarding but if you if you
don't want to deal with that and if you
wanna be able to pick this up for easily
then you can totally do that just play
on I think it's called just the story or
story in the sword or something like
that which is the easiest difficulty
because like I said before as much as I
do like the combat I know a lot of
people don't but as much as I like the
combat I think the best thing about this
game is its story and characters and
that's that can be kind of tough to pick
up just because there is a lot of lore
here yeah there is a glossary though
that like tells you about all the
characters I don't dig too deep spoilers
but it tells you about all the
characters it'll tell you about the
monsters and kind of give you background
in the world and stuff like that and
also the physical addition I believe the
switch one the the console ones came
with a compendium that would fill you in
on the events of the world which is like
I don't know it wasn't that long so I
think the harder learning curve for this
game is just figuring out what's going
on but now that we've done that should
we do some side quests maybe hunt some
monsters what do you guys want to see in
the chat do we want to you know check
out some side quests or continue our
search and keep going with the story
yeah this is a fun one we will do this
quickly I have to find
yep venez correct this will be available
on switch tomorrow well I'm getting a
little sneak peak here
I would say like for people who have
never played The Witcher like what's
another game that's probably similar in
play style if they're curious on how to
you know have the beginning sorry I
would say it's that stench
hmm it's similar to Bioware games for
sure a wyvern armor right into this this
story and branching narratives are
reminiscent of Bioware games I'd say the
combat kind of feels like like a much
deeper Assassin's Creed game maybe like
the early Assassin's Creed's though not
origins and Odyssey
[Music]
[Music]
Secor the reviews in progress yeah in
progress we it's a long game I want to
make sure I see all of it see all the
important bits hopefully later this week
for sure later otherwise I might be in
trouble
nice it's actually kind of pretty I know
right good and that's the other thing
too like even though the graphics don't
look super great doc the monster design
is is really good character design
nice snowboarding I guess I think in the
ps4 version there was an achievement if
you could like slide for 100 meters or
something man the switch has just been
killing it in my opinion they've been
just adding so many games and you know
newer new games coming out to tomorrow
we're probably gonna be playing some
overwatch on switch I'm super curious
about how that's gonna run - I'm always
curious and then I'm always impressed
yeah that's usually how it goes for me
Tony says let's enjoy the game and peace
no console wars yeah like I think the
thing that people forget is like you
know I don't think they were setting out
with the goal of being oh this is gonna
be the best version of this game but
it's gonna be the best it can be for the
console and I think everyone's well
aware that obviously this looks better
on a console or a PC
I know you guys were just all spoiled
brats that's really what it is at the
end of the day each and every one of us
that's like how far gaming has come that
were we're at that point now because I
recently actually went back and started
playing Final Fantasy 7 which is great
so far because you know I played other
versions but not that one and I feel
like that's everyone's favorite so you
know playing that version I still think
it's great and when you think about the
time that it came out you know I was
really impressed but I can see like I
want to see people like gamers from the
current era go back and play older games
like there's no complaining about
graphics and stuff like that back then
everything was amazing
so alright repaired my sword nice
let's get over here let's hunt this
Shrieker
so if this if you've never played The
Witcher before and you plan on getting
this I recommend doing the monster hunts
because they seem pretty simple they
seem like oh you know just go out and
kill this monster but a lot of times
there's more interesting stuff you can
learn about it about the creature about
the story about the world pretty much
all the content in this game no matter
what you decide to is elevated to the
level of like the main story see what
Chet has to say
amigo said if you haven't played witcher
3 yet you have never played game with
such story i mean you didn't mention
there's a ton of lore and it's the third
one so probably a lot snatches cows and
goats
fortunately the scoring a man and all
over him I'll save that fat boy Huntsman
under the old lord well he said enough
enough claimed he put a stop to it
drive the beast away mmm took a hatchet
laid an ambush for the Shrieker beyond
the moat
where the fields start it's where we
found him
good stretch toe the crown of a tree
like gossamer took half a day to collect
the parts put him in a grave
I know times are until hackle here I
need you to cough up a bit more coin Pro
which are strats right here I start
higher right that's the that's the see
it's not 300 City says you shake a lot a
few crowns to dear annoyance level I
feel like I need one of those like in my
everyday life shake a few crumbs to
thank for this he's getting more annoyed
I suppose I cannot die you got a risk in
your net for height I'm a professional
took a look at this Shrieker anyone
around here know more about the beast
borzoi son Simcoe does so the ARA with
his own eyes but you might find the
lidar to chat with still mourns his
father and me things I see well I find
him only homestead I told the toy kid
when he lost his dad the mother passed
long ago ruff yeah Jonathan said one of
the only games as 200 plus hours I have
actually beaten in its entirety
including DLCs still have to manage 200
percent every quest side quest dome down
I just want to I want to avenge your
father but to do that I gotta know what
killed him
don't you know that name doesn't mean
much to me describe the beast tell me
what it looked like something like a
rooster but huge with a lizard's tail I
heard their barking in the woods trying
to see what you were on about
there were dad in the bushes a hole
through his belly moaning screaming I
wanted to help but how could I take care
kid bit of which dramatic right there
make you feel better
put his mind at ease I mean it's pretty
sad and he's gonna be traumatized for
life yeah that's the other thing with
this game it can be a lot of times there
are no happy endings
curly cheese that this game will make
being late on public transportation so
much more bearable I feel that I know
that's what I'm looking forward to most
is playing this on BART playing this and
Dragon Quest 11 on Barrios I can I can
take public transportation all the time
now I know right you're like begging for
delays at that point we have a mission
to finish all right
here we go
mussels caked in blood didn't give up
without a fight hmm that's that dude
tracks are we regular here monster must
have started staggering was wounded most
likely right nice the dog Oh weakened
him a little bit monster blood
mmm-hmm is lost the tracks in the water
oh snap
is there any lagging graphics look
acceptable says Ching I mean we haven't
really noticed anything
it actually obviously doesn't do 60 I
think someone in the chats at 24 through
30 is about where it is but it's been
pretty stable I haven't noticed any huge
framerate drops for anything that being
cited in novigrad which historically is
a little bit rougher I'm going to
meditate first and then I'm gonna check
the bestiary see if I have anything on
jackin it streaker there we go great
shot dad are ya trikona Doyle I wonder
if I can craft that I bet I can't
I gotta go to alchemy there we go
dang I need some calcium I know what it
finds some and I don't have the other
one
alright well going without any
preparation see if I can pull this off
okay we've meditated
so we've meditated all my potions are
full you may not even be here
yes brah so it does come with what use
won't come okay cough it does come with
the flow of the LCS well I was rudely
interrupted by the sweeper Smokeout yeah
we're gonna see if I can do that we
should have another bomb wonder if this
bomb won't even work for them might as
well try otherwise we're going back to
town let through another exit got an
abbot before it gets away won't get away
this time it's pretty big
yeah it is
oh nice okay you just turned around and
was like chasing me oh oh yeah he's
injured very supposedly more is full
there yeah that is Fric cat gravity
overwatch on switch tomorrow curious see
how that's gonna be I'm praying Lucy is
in Jersey I really want her to come play
overwatch for me again but she probably
is very busy important person I was
excited you were available snakes I feel
like you've been pretty busy lately to
the big news no big reason I was able to
because I have to play more for their
[Music]
what Abbas seems like trash-talking with
the monster what up Eddie be welcome
thanks for tuning in happy Monday yo
Joshua what up
Oh bleeding
[Music]
stop runnin and get over here
maybe I should have prepared a bit
better
[Music]
back off let the potion heal me oh yeah
oh no oh he almost scooped you up
almost I just thought flashback of like
ancestors getting snatched up by the
crow did those have some pretty fancy
footwork yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no I thought I had a shot ready I guess
I did all right we block those who block
those I'm very much one of those players
that like I feel like real-life
movements will help me somehow coding
eyes when they get loves my last potion
oh I think you've got this he's low to
Frasso says so much patient from this
fight I normally go charging in and die
about 800 OB if this is an easier
difficulty I would have just totally
done that or if I or if it was like New
Game+ I already had on my like potions
and decoctions and stuff but I am
hurting for supplies here again
we nice scratches back real quick out
[Applause]
all right
and how much damage does it do if he
scoops here we've avenged his father
doing more good deeds kind of that was I
feel like that was more of a good deed
than the first one we did I'd say so
but how do they know if you've killed it
if you haven't decapitated and put on
your horse exactly
gotta get the proof
no quick detour while we're here
mode asks so this out on the eShop in
four hours for a UK eShop I'm actually
not a hundred percent sure how the shop
works when it comes to like the
different regions but I mean as long as
it's the 15 I would assume that it would
be available as well the 15th wherever
you are
was there a day one patch well it's
technically not day one yet oh yeah sure
so I didn't have to install a patch when
I downloaded this however it is like 32
gigs or something like that so which I
guess isn't a whole lot but it can be a
lot for a switch brain like I for
instance took took a while and I had to
delete some stuff off my switch in order
to make space do this
I guess that is something to consider -
another reason why maybe getting the
cartridge is a good idea
great yeah that is one thing about the
switch like if there was anything I
really didn't like I just feel like it
needs more space yeah I want all the
games yeah I got a 256 micro SD card
which seemed like a lot at the time but
they're dumb Google killed me took out
that murdered the Shrieker and then the
ghoul gotcha yeah Michael does bring up
a good point - this games on sale a lot
it's cheaper and it is the best looking
version so if you have a PC you haven't
played this game that might be the way
to go but you know so far just don't
join it get a taste the loading screens
- which also I found there long but they
also seem about as long as the the ps4
and Xbox one versions when I played
those once again obviously the PC is
much quicker
yeah I feel like it's kind of unfair to
compare anything to its PC version yeah
it's like we get it guys we already know
this
there it is there we go go go oh yeah
I'll leave the ghouls alone and just
turn this question go make this little
boy feel better without magic
just hand them the side we're gonna head
sure I'm sure that will make them feel
better
oh man should I play some Gwen how much
time do we have we have like half an
hour still should I play around a point
someone said around of Gwen perhaps do
it I don't think you can pretty sure you
can't use GOG saves in the switch
version that will be really cool though
especially because divinity right had
that cross save with steam and switch
it'd be really cool if you could move
your saves from steam - yeah your switch
Thank You Master Witcher your reward
take much but as they say take care of
the pennies alright now I can be a good
witch here or should I just take the
money I mean I want to keep the coin
oh no I'm orphan I need it more than I
do and they call which is unfeeling and
human well I thank you from the bottom
of me hard
yeah you know we're just doing all the
good deeds today even if that one might
have been on exit
[Music]
Spa cider for tea or bad Roy curd me
loudest no anxiety burst n button why he
got sure to please well to make a bat a
few rounds of cards Gwent specifically
[Music]
all right let's get a rundown of this
card game here for anyone who hasn't
played so it's three rounds you start
out with ten cards and basically you
have to have more points on the board
than your opponent but you have to keep
in mind that your your resources are
limited you only have ten cards you kind
of have to be careful unfortunately I
haven't played much Gwent in the save so
my deck isn't that good I may not even
win we'll see you did max bet ten coins
we got to make our money back from what
we donated to I think I you like haggled
with him and then he told me keep a
Gwent standalone game Colucci says I
know I'm surprised that throne breaker
or just went in general isn't on the
Nintendo switch yet that would be really
cool yeah the music is good
pass we can I pass go get a hold it
oh that's why the microphone is blocking
circle there's only one round dang he's
got eight cards and I have five
oh don't think I'm gonna win this one
Daniel Duke so so excited to play this
can't wait to lose sleep playing in bed
isn't that the truth that's definitely
like the bane of my existence when it
comes to owning like a handheld device
it has like all the games I really like
to play like I'll play awake for 30
minutes where I go to sleep five hours
later or fall asleep with your switch in
your hand still on done that there's
only been once where I accidentally
dropped it on my face cuz you're likely
going to start falling asleep I was like
I'm not doing that no way that's
dangerous well I'm out of cards No see
if you can pull this out you have more
at the moment I know I'm winning depends
that he's got okay so far we're good see
what his last card is all right
[Applause]
okay all right what should we do now if
I continue this story I have more side
quests in monster hunts we can do I can
just explore ease they're part of the
game you guys want to see yeah let us
know you guys we have about 20 minutes
left of the stream so obviously I can't
go everywhere in the world because I
haven't unlocked certain spots but I can
I don't know
check out specific areas in the meantime
I will meditate very important that no
alcohol I got a good good smell
cuz now I can't if you don't have
alcohol your inventory you can't
replenish your doesn't matter okay well
I purchased some alcohol see if anyone
else chimes and if not I'll probably
just do more Monster quest cuz those are
kind of stand-alone and yeah I won't
spoil anything or get lost of anyone
angel this is this includes all the DLC
in one go so you don't have to worry
about trying actually you'll see if you
get this
we got one request for a side quest show
me what you got
Podrick is asking about the pack in
goodies with the switch version I know
you kind of mentioned something that was
coming with the actually let me look at
the details here
see ya see ya
[Music]
hmm I know something does come with this
complete what is it what are you looking
at I'm like you mentioned earlier with
the physical addition that some others
oh I'm not they tweeted about it a while
okay so there it is it should be the
universe compendium map game card it
looks like anything like that come up
the box so you do get some extra goodies
as well
okay side quest that's kind of a boring
one alright so with the Witcher
Wild Hunt complete edition the physical
copy you get the game box game card with
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt base game hearts
of stone and blood and wine expansions
and 16 DLC you get stickers you get a
map and you get The Witcher Universe
compendium it's kind of interesting to
me how like digital and physical copies
have reversed in a way where it's like
we get the digital first and then
they'll come out with like a physical
version or something like that like apex
is releasing physical copies like the
bloodline and the lifeline Edition which
I was actually considering getting both
I guess that makes sense right cuz it's
a pretty big investment probably to you
know print all those boxes seal them all
like ship them you might as well you
know do what apex did release it
digitally it took off and like alright
well now we've got money and there are
people who probably like this game
enough that they will buy them they
might pick up a physical copy just have
it on their shelf and usually those
things come with you know more goodies
like you get like exclusive skins for
like Liam club but home
if you do buy the physical copies and
it's less beautiful but yeah what was
that about what's become of me in the
elder years refused a roof over my head
by a common Cheryl I was born in opals
daughter my brother and I we managed a
manor for years what happened to him a
caller came one day a drifter hunter it
wasn't long before we fell in love and
Wed we prepared to leave the manor my
brother he took offense refused to bid
me farewell years on I returned but
found no sign of him folk claimed
monsters have infested our home come to
nest there I could take care of this
money you're no ordinary man would be so
eager don't fret it's all the same to me
if I did you're honest
the house is east of here take this key
once you've driven off the bases look
for a chest my treasure savings really
they're yours what'll they leave you
with all I need and if it comes to it
I've other heirlooms to sell but I know
you witches don't work for free I could
never let you go without honest pay gods
keep you
all right time to kill some monsters
reclaim this house
come on roach you go dream inside girl
in Mario costume one I can see why they
didn't choose to do that good especially
after playing like Skyrim and you can
get links costing I was like I'd be kind
of cool amiibo smart where's my Geralt
amiibo that's what I want I can add it
next to my other Geralt statutes
Wolfgang says all Hilda Witcher
sometimes I like to just think what if
this like real-life monsters just
straight up invading my home but nowhere
to go I would probably do the same thing
don't clear it out take all my stuff if
you want afterwards yeah
para his family
manner the old woman mentioned
what just happened man your horse took
that like a champ oh yeah that's true
though
I guess that would be more terrifying
smart monsters setting up traps and
stuff tripwire
something's not right
problem solved
the tripwire
problem solved like oh he just looks at
it long enough
one less to worry about a lot of traps
in here sort of addict gotta get up
there somehow finally just long enough
to reach that upper level I was like
100% you playing this Ally you just
watched shades of black
your reflexes have slowed hope you're
not hurt
those were my traps breath oh yeah
didn't expect to see you either you one
of them then you know I work alone
question is what are you doing here
waiting for them the ones trying to kill
me I don't got nothing to fear from me
took a job from an old woman supposed to
get rid of the monsters here did that
already count on you remembering that
when you collect your pay
[Music]
who'd you piss off this time Emperor
just decided to get rid of me I'm an
inconvenient witness after all I've run
into loads of man out of killing ever
since I left LA Queen now I understand
all the traps got me real careful for
good reason
[Music]
so he already clear out the house this
if you didn't play with your tour if you
don't simulator what you're to save
right this mission will be different
you'll come here and you'll clear out
monsters and ghosts but because I
simulated with you to save Lisa it
brings that it brings back this
character from which you to that's
pretty cool it does a lot of stuff like
that that's hard to know unless I've
played The Witcher 2 recently but it
makes for more interesting playthroughs
if you decide to replay I kind of like
that because you know not everybody will
go back and play the first few before
trying this one out so they'll feel less
like they're missing out on story yeah
that was epic
right
secret said who's excited for des
traning only three weeks I honestly
can't believe that games three weeks ago
right
I snuck up it did the same time it
didn't well I think it feels like it
snuck up because I still hardly have any
idea who it was really about I'm like
that Charlie armed four assassins
they're just Scouts came to see if Lewis
was telling the truth
rest must be waiting nearby and your old
pal probably knows where he was the only
one knew I'd be here must have told them
I think me and ever do for a little chat
could be interesting love to see it come
along sided to which you should loosen
this tone that ridiculous biceps close
to me it's one of those places it's hard
to find if you don't know where to look
that like one vein and you would be able
to donate so much [ __ ]
how'd you mate it was before fall test
kissed this world goodbye
Lewis was a wanted man big hefty bounty
on his head
normal contacts were hard to come by so
I decide yeah John so far the frame rate
he's pretty except really dips but
nothing super significant and nothing
that has attracted from my experience so
far it seems pretty rock-solid man yeah
I feel like the only times I've really
seen a drop or when you're like exiting
a cutscene entering a cutscene which is
a whole lot better than happening like
mid combat or when you're like fighting
a boss yeah that being said I've said a
couple times wouldn't novigrad yet which
is oh yeah which is you know one of the
intense er areas but so far it seems
pretty solid it's definitely not 60
frames a second like if you want to play
this 60 frames a second this is not the
way to do it but you know that 24 to 30
seems to be pretty accurate it seems I
haven't really noticed anything
all right let out were you taking
let though fine Louis or Louie or
however it's pronounced
like how we still have that Shrieker
ahead let's go yeah it gives Geralt
perks keep it there yeah so I've got a
Griffin head I've got that hand I've got
no icing system short some sense
something
Daniel Dukes the expansions are not
separate downloads for the switch
version everything's included great good
to see you oh yeah of course
we're all mates who's your friend
damn that was your a thing
[Music]
Arno Vestas men showed up at the man you
were the only one knew I was there for a
while since our yourself perhaps I find
a call with hmm with your help
you've not been here five minutes and
already you've offended me twice no way
so worthy of scum like ding oh I love
that that with the last line it was like
no that's the last straw
we're brawling now
says she who don't let these bandits get
ya goose
lie still or you'll bleed to death tell
me where Vestas men are I'll give you
something to staunch the bleeding
I'm curious how much does the life of an
old mate get you these days the things I
showed up one day often hard for the
bounty on your head off word as I
understand
do it please though I'm gonna get the
upside my medicine gotta understand lose
you don't be trained men like me
time to see Wester going with you
man I thought for sure we were gonna
chop his head off right there but now
that this is worse actually just let him
bleed out surrounded by all his dead
buddies like dang talk about a serious
case of Monday's alright so it continues
almost done I think is the last step
should finish up right on time why have
I never heard of him gooo goes by
different names Brandon Jackson man if
any said Google different name I will
say as much as I love this game
the horse back riding rise is a not age
than you better still be pretty rough
that's it roach
the incidental dialogue in the Kings
honey there's some good stuff
what's in the barn got company run him
find your parents
tell them to grab what that was valuable
to take you and flee got it
good give this to your mother now run I
didn't realize he was scared until they
started talking to an open station
stay here and don't interfere no matter
what happens
plug your ears
towel colliding with Gerald Oh ding Paul
a lightning or something
shut up all of you
oh let though of gummit need some photos
you will certainly fetch a high above
dear life
really how much enough to buy me in a
state in covere where I will lie about
eating fruit till the end of my days not
bad not every man gets to know the price
on his hand
most men would prefer not to have one
why have you come to make my life easier
we will pass him by decided it was time
to finally meet the famous Arno vest or
in person I am flattered Shane will not
get to know one another better why going
somewhere no simply because I will kill
you in the moment wanna kill me but you
don't even know me not nice think I have
to punish you for that but I won't kill
you I'll just cut off your hands
cut off all your hair like this guy one
man after the other till the end of your
days
those stumps will remind you of the
mistake you made
I haven't time to exchange two words
with the man it's a wrap now oh man I
love it wouldn't like the lead guy is
always like do you realize what you've
done
we have no quarrel with you but one
false move and and what you will end
like him what say you to that what do I
say simple you're as good as dead they
really killed him
because he just taking a breather let's
see Oh interesting angel said the
developers made a point of going to no
forgot on their video on the Nintendo
channel it's fine don't worry yeah I so
when I see the game a while ago I got to
explore the whole area and it seemed
pretty good I just you know want to make
sure yeah as things change like really
in the heat of battle
yeah where's the homie he's not dead get
up man
sometimes
hmm dingleberry envenom something's
fishy
he's really dead
[Music]
nice is asleep
the anticipations killing me
okay all I needed
they'd have cut your head off if I
hadn't been here hmm so you proved
useful after all could have told me no
fun in man
you all right you're conscious but the
sanguinary envenom could still kill you
got the antidote hmm saddlebag take you
to the minute couple of days I'll be
like new what was it for that whole
farce Tolia had been on the run since la
queen loads of pursuers God ambush once
almost died so I decided it was time to
end it once and for all
found bastards gang and paid off his
arbol list you just witnessed the rest
of the story
what if he'd crossed you Mike Lewis I
had a risk you hadn't cut down every
last witness I'd be a free man
Natha love Gullit he's dead
no did that would have spread across the
continent in days wouldn't have done it
if you'd let me in on your plan told you
not to get involved well my plans in
shambles
I shouldn't disappear
you could wait things out at karrimor in
with your friends from the school of the
wolf uh-huh
no thanks cuz in badly tell them I sent
you
they'll understand give you space care
more than you say hmm got some loose
ends to tie up but then I'll head there
help you somehow evening no thanks I'll
be fine so see what care more see you
wolf
all right yeah I was already dying
because I had literally just said I like
this guy's like he's cool and I'm like
no don't die so soon but yeah finish
right on time actually well there you
have it you guys that is a little bit of
Witcher 3 on switch it is available
tomorrow so if you like what you saw
make sure you get your hands on the game
and yeah 11:00 a.m. Pacific time every
weekday is when you can tune in and
watch some GameSpot live so thanks for
joining us and hope to see you tomorrow
we actually might do two streams
tomorrow there's a lot going on this
week so we'll see but make sure you tune
in tomorrow and every other week day for
game spot live until then we'll see you
guys see ya
you